this is a production of cornell
university
thanks ryan
yeah crystal and i have a
a small vegetable and seed farm here in
johnstown new york
and where we focus
primarily on seed garlic
and some small vegetables and we also
have incorporated
some ongoing research
of our favorite topic is to improve soil
health so
um
we were able to get a grant from north
east sarah to continue some of the work
that i was doing at the hudson valley
farm hub
too and
to plant vegetables
um in a vegetarian cover crop
and i thought it would be good to tell
the story a little bit how we got there
um to begin with and how we ended up you
know what our conclusions were from this
basically five-year
journey of
trying to work with planting vegetables
to a cover crop
all right if i can just
find a way to here we go
all right
um first uh ryan asked me to
briefly introduce for some of the folks
that are not as familiar
with this system
is to talk about the fact that we're
rolling and crimping a cover crop and
trying to plant the vegetables through
this
well some of the principles that we've
all learned from some of the work that
have been done extensively with field
crops is that
we know that if you want to be
successful with this you want to plant
your fall cover crops early
means like september 1st is a good date
we also want to make sure that we are
rolling and crimping which is this tool
that is either mounted before or behind
the tractor we'll see some more pictures
of that later on
um when plants are in it anthesis that
means then they are in full flower
not when they have pollinated because
that's when they actually can set seeds
um
now
cereals um have an anticipate usually of
about that last about a week
the legumes are we consider to be
indeterminate
and there is no real antejesus point
it's more like there is constant
flowering happening
makes it much more difficult
to kill that cover crop
and
especially under the organic conditions
that we're working with
so about five years ago um we
with the pro farmer program at the
hudson valley farmhub
we had a
deep interest in seeing how we could
stop tilling and plant a vegetable
directly to a cover crop
and we did a number of different cover
crops
of which i will just focus right now on
the arson winter piece and some of the
hairy vets that we did
and um by pure coincidence um as we had
so much land in cover crops and we
didn't really plan want to find all that
egg grits into vegetables uh we planted
some buckwheat
with the no-till drill uh true austrian
winter piece
and what we were finding is that that
cover crop was killed while the one that
we just rolled and crimped was not
you can see here what happens with the
no-till drill is that when you slice it
every seven inches it actually provides
a very effective kill
to arsenal winter piece and what we also
found uh with hairy vetch as well
so in order to accomplish uh the killing
of a cover crop
um that is an indeterminate plant you
have to do something more than just
rolling it and crimping it you actually
have to slice it without bringing up
soil of course
here you can see where's the
airy vetch
and again you can see
this no-till drill
has cultures
to allow the seeds to
actually go into the ground and of
course the seed box is empty for this
particular situation
and then
it's a better slide right here
and then we plant it with a
very specific no-till planter very
expensive piece of equipment
uh we planted directly into uh the hair
effect we planted sweet corn
and then in the arson winter piece we
planted some broccoli and cauliflower
you can see there's a lot of open ground
there when you're using 100 legume mix
there is
an awful lot of ground that is still
exposed
and this is what it looked like right
after planting
so it's still pretty pretty clean
a little bit later
but if you take a closer look you can
see that a lot of weeds are going to be
um
establishing
to the extent where like
you're gonna lose your crop if you don't
address the wheat issues there
so there wasn't a high residue
cultivator um but a lilliston rolling
cultivator was used that was a thing in
the barn and one of our pro farmers
painted it up nicely
and
we used that actually quite successfully
um to go through the ashley winter piece
so the osha winter piece was not
something that
needed a very specific piece of
equipment
but because it's pretty rough and the
distance between the um
lilistans is quite wide and it didn't do
a phenomenal job
a lot of hoeing was required and even
despite the hauling
the weeds were getting in
but what's interesting to see here when
you look at the slide
it's taken on august
and then we did a side-by-side
comparison between where we did
conventional till
you can see that this crop is wilting
so the
water holding capacity of the soil is so
much greater
in the
plots where we didn't till
the potential till before planting so we
were really fascinated the structure was
much better
in that plot so we were encouraged to
continue that work
but
um here is the kicker is that
in order to be successful there um we
had an army of people hand holding it
and keep the weeds down
so conclusions really of um
this uh whole trial
is that um
um
first of all
that legumes are difficult to roll in
crimp and you're going to have to have
access to a kind of expensive piece of
equipment
which right now is more possible with
usda grants that have been made
to make
no-till drills available to your usda
office and i encourage everybody to
talk to their local uca asian it is
possible to apply for our grants to get
a machine like that in your county
um it's difficult to control weeds
unless you have access to the equipment
that can deal with high residue so there
are high residue cultivators
and a little sun rolling cultivator is
not the ideal piece of equipment high
residue cultivators are very specific
and get a lot closer to the crop and
allow you to do much better weed control
the other thing we found is that similar
or even better yields were in the
no-till plots
unless you know under the
condition that you keep your weeds under
control
and of course the positive results that
we had which only accomplished because
of very high labor input which we didn't
feel that um
did had a commercial application yet for
organic farmers
but we were intrigued
and i wanted to continue and then for
2018 we tried to continue this trial at
roxbury farm but as soon after rolling
we actually discovered that
the local
rye and harry vets was purchased
was full of wheat seeds
and we had to abandon it so here again
it's one of these things where you learn
along the way if you are doing something
like this you you cannot
uh afford uh to get sea that is not
completely clean
and and do you have to be more careful
in preparing your seed bed so you have a
very clean sea but so you also don't
have overwintering weeds as well
then in 2019 when we moved to philia
farm in johnstown we were able to obtain
a grant through north east here
and we set up an experimental trial
with 27 plots whereby the premise was
like
we know we don't have good wheat control
with just hairy vetch
what about if we mix in a small amount
of twitter kale and see
um if that will provide it with the
optimum amount of weed control
let's do 20 pounds of 3d kale all the
way up to 80 pounds of twitter kale
and see what difference we will make
what we had learned from our colleagues
that doing field crops is that
biomass really matters in order to have
optimum weed control
and we know that the biomass of just
hairy vets especially in the northern
regions is about two and a half thousand
pounds
and what we learned from our colleagues
that they said well you wanna wanna have
about between five and seven thousand
pounds of biomass in order to really
suppress these weeds
so this is what we did and this is what
the um
what it looked like
we had a randomized
way of looking at all these different
seedings
replicated three times each particular
seeding rate
and this is what the hair the triticale
and the hairy effects look like the
following year
in 2020
and then we wrote and crimped it um
sometime
around the beginning of june
when the triticale was anticipated
and um what we already right away
learned is that at the very lower um
rates of critical
uh the hairy
batch is very very well
a
lot
which then gave a problem for us
um to be able to plant in it afterwards
you can see here where the brown spot is
that is the control plot
so we could make a comparison between
conventional till and the different
seeding rates
another aspect of the grant was to be
able to see like if we take a regular
planter
how do we have to modify it
in order to plant undernotal conditions
and one of the things is that
you can take a regular transplanter and
plan with no-till
given that you do have a double disc
opener in front of the transplanter
and that you modify
the uh closing wheels
uh closing is more of an issue actually
under no till conditions than opening uh
is what we found is that these regular
and i'm gonna put my mouse right on here
those are the regular closing wheels
they have a little bit of a bevel there
a little a little bit of an edge
we had to replace them with the
old-fashioned closing wheels
um
and you see there is no bevel there so
they wouldn't start riding on the hard
grounds
the other thing is we had to mount
coulters in front
of the transplanter and here we used
wavy holders that later on were replaced
with straight holders we found that the
straight cultures work really well
you see those cinder blocks sitting on
here to provide some extra weight
that is actually
more of an issue about the fact that we
drove so much on the trial plots in
order to get all these different
seedings done
and we rolled and crimped twice
which caused so much compaction
that we
had to
put weight on the coil to wheels but i
think that under normal conditions
that should not be as much of an issue
that was really something that we we
were self-inflicted um
in a way due to the setup of the trial
and here we are uh planting uh cabbage
uh we chose for passat
young from the height of bay or seat we
had a conversation with him
and we wanted a quick closing cap as we
knew that sweet corn is a crop that can
be done relatively
successful under those conditions to
provide weed control through shading
and we hope that facade will be one of
those cabbages that would also
establish relatively quickly
to provide the shade that was needed
you can see the hairy vetch is not fully
killed we did not have access to a
no-till drill
the only thing that we used here is a
roller and crimper
so not ideal
and you can see that the hairy vet
started coming back the cabbage started
growing
and we started monitoring the progress
of different
cabbages
now
what really came out of this trial is
inconclusive really that there's any
difference between
the seeding rates
and eventual yield
we also found that the compaction was a
great limiting factor
in order to allow the cabbage to thrive
the way that they should be so there's
definitely something inherent in the
fact that we did this trial the way we
did that we didn't see the results that
we would like to see
but then so we counted
how many heads we had
and how much they weighed and translated
that to yield per acre and as you can
see here the yields varied anywhere
between 20 to 30 000 pounds
to the acre
and um
um
yeah
there was nothing that really came
forward that we said like well um we we
do need a higher rate or a lower rate of
critical
so what we did we said like let's do an
extension of the trial because this is
inconclusive data let's do this one more
time and just do the higher um seating
rates
with 3d kill
so one more time the conclusions of that
first year of trial with no obvious
correlate between the seed mixes
um
no obvious difference in population
that's between 20 and 40 pounds so
there's another interesting thing
veg seed especially oregano is expensive
so we really don't have to up our
population of veg to get a good
establishment
and then what i already said that the
seed mixed with the low triticale were
lodged
and that the yield is negatively
impacted
and that conventional planting equipment
can successfully be adapted for planting
to a cover crop
one other fun thing we did
actually was not
um by design completely
because we grew some shallots next to
the garlic
and this field was in garlic the
previous year
and the shelves were harvested later
than the garlic and we ended up planting
one bed of treaty kale and veg
about a month later
than
the vet then the twitty kale and vets on
the right and you can see in the spring
a phenomenal difference in development
so just to illustrate how important it
is to get your cover crop
established in time uh in the fall
and then we wrote in crimp this time
with the high with the 80 to 100 pounds
of triticale
we had phenomenal coverage uh in the
field
we ended up hand planting winter squash
in there
we chose winter squash we knew that
nitrogen might become an issue
and
since winter squash has a lower need for
nitrogen and cabbage we hope to have
more success with that
and maybe the rates
were even higher than 80 to 100 pounds
we actually didn't exactly know
what the rates were
um
as you can see here we covered them in
order to protect them against cucumber
beetles with floating row covers
but the plans soon petered out
and weeds actually took over even with
the heavy cover so
again this was not a great success
so the conclusions is that cereal cover
crops to be used for boiling crimping
under the organic growing conditions is
really not advisable
but unless you and sarah will be talking
about this after this presentation
unless you're playing a legume also at
the hudson valley farm up we had very
good luck with growing edamame
and green beans after growing a straight
crop of rye and rolling and crimping
dots so that worked well
but when you try to plant um
cabbage or cauliflower broccoli sweet
corn and even winter squash um you
really need to find a way
to plant that directly to a
legume but then the problem is when you
only use a legume
you really need to be able to kill
that cover crop effectively so that's
where you need either to slice it
with a no-till drill
or other options would be to tarp it and
i think later this afternoon we'll be
talking about tarping
tarping will be an effective way to
kill your legume and would also kill any
weeds that are still present
within your legume cover crop
and i think that ultimately
when you don't tarp and
even when you can kill it with a no-till
drill
i would say planting directed to a
legume
would be mostly feasible
if the weeds can be controlled with a
high residue cultivator
that can go a bit closer
to the crops
than
than say a littlest enrolling cultivator
i'm actually at the end i did it pretty
rapidly i don't need my full time and i
actually um i'm very happy to open it up
for
questions that people have uh regarding
this so
um and i'm happy all to go back to
slides if people
uh weren't completely clear about uh
exactly
what was being done
so thank you
thank you john paul yeah more time for
questions and discussion is good
you did well there
very succinct thank you for uh for
sharing that those iterations over time
it's pretty impressive
um how you stay persistent
to
continue
does that mean that next year
i'm waiting for folks to put stuff in
the chat i have a question does that
mean that um next year you you will not
trial the system or you'll try to
acquire high residue or what would be
the next step for you
um
actually we're going to go one year back
to um
introducing some more bare fallow uh
system because one of the weeds
was not really very clear in the picture
but one persistent wheat in our system
about medium red clover
and
so we want to flush that out flush it
out a little bit
is to reduce the enormous
seed bank we have of red clover
most people say like they scratched
their head like wow we have a seed bank
of gallon soga or
you know and we have a seed bank of red
clover so don't ask me how that happened
it was it was in a hayfield for
about 20 25 years and we turned it over
into crops
and what we're finding is that mostly
what we're dealing with right now are
either perennial weeds
um
or we have rudbeckia for example as a
wheat
and medium red clover so next year
we are going to do some intensive cover
cropping
and uh
with some bear fellows in between to
clean these fields up a little bit more
i i did see that red clover in there i
wanted to follow up on that too
much about that um we have quite a
couple questions in here steve
asks why triticale versus wheat or
cereal rye
yeah and that was one of these other
things um
the idea was
that triticale might
flower a little bit later than rye
and
again this was based on hearsay
and i don't think that proved to be
correct we we wanted to do a little bit
later rolling on crimping
hoping that the later you rolling
crimped the vetch
maybe the more effective uh the killing
of the vetch would be that did not prove
to be true either so
um there is no reason to switch
rye for triticale
and uh robert asks
what is considered a high residue
cultivator and i had a similar question
oh what's your experience with them and
and
you know you could talk more about high
residue cultivators
yeah there is a great picture i
think it's still in the field um the
book published by sarah
if you would actually
uh google high res to do cultivator it
might come up uh it's a great picture
that uh would show you there and
why it works the way it works is that
um people who are familiar with the
no-till drill especially the the john
deere type no-till drill
there are press wheels running in front
of the culture that actually holds
um the the crop residue down
before the counter hits it well in this
case the
the colder wheels
and there will be two of them
are holding the residue down
and then the the knife slides underneath
um the crop residue so holding that
cover crop in place is really important
that you don't start
pushing
the crop residue in front of your
cultivators so by just holding this down
and slicing it and then go underneath
with a knife is what makes this thing
work really effectively
and it's an expensive piece of equipment
um
i
priced one out and that's already back
in 2017 and back then a two row
was already fourteen thousand dollars
and given where prices are right now
i don't know
a million
so it's one of the things that um could
also be
looked at to obtain
through usda if people are really
interested if a number of growers come
together
and
[Music]
say like we would like to
have usda purchase something like that
with us along with the no-till drill
this would be
um a roller crimper
these are tools that really help with
soil health
one of the things i'm not discouraged
about is is that
if you can work out the kings it does
contribute tremendously to soil health
soil aggregation
in a field that is not being tilled is
so much greater
than under conventional till i wanted to
i wanted to ask you about flail mowing i
i know some people say that they're
addicted to tillage i've heard you say
that john paul
i'm addicted to flail mowing i like it
and i saw
it looks good afterwards and yeah um
and uh we found that it kills things
like vetch and that seems to be like one
of your your primary issues
you um
you know there's trade-offs there
because things break down quicker but
have you thought about that or um
is there a role there for for mowing it
yeah i think it's an excellent situation
ryan i think especially um it would make
the uh cultivation afterwards so much
easier
because now you're breaking up the hairy
vetch in smaller pieces and then
i guess
what what it was is that we were
stubborn in the sense that we were
hoping that somehow miraculously
a cover crop would control the wheat we
just plant and walk away from it that
was kind of the attitude we have
not advisable so
if you know that you're not going to
control the weeds anyway and you're
going to have
and you don't have access to a high
residue cultivator flail mowing is a
really great option
because you can get in there
with a little slim rolling cultivator
and um actually
there there is more
ability than to to
allow it to work the way it's supposed
to work
uh by doing some healing
under the the um when the stems are long
it actually prevents the littlest
enrolling cultivator
from
doing the the work it's supposed to do
with this the healing part it kind of
clogs up a little bit right i mean at
the end of the row you're out there with
a crowbar and removing quite a bit of
the arsenal winter piece or the hairy
vets
so it works but it doesn't really work
so
um
really yes
flail mowing excellent idea
and you've been doing it for um a long
time right ryan
and some of our trials yeah that's that
that was our go-to
we were fortunate to have one that was
kind of side mounted so we i noticed in
your case you you had it on the rear
right so you're driving over the cover
crop prior to you know
trying to roll it i don't know if that
um
you didn't try to drive backwards or
anything like that did you
yeah
that's that's an issue with with with
mowing or or rolling
for determination i guess
yeah i mean if you if you have a heavier
tractor and
the flail mower is behind the tires
that area does not get flail molds as
well of course
um there are not too many front mounted
flail mowers around um
that i that i am aware of
so sight mounting uh definitely helps
well good afternoon everyone and thank
you very much for having me here today
ryan
um to talk to you about the potential of
rye mulch to suppress white mold in
no-till soybean and dry bean
and today i'm going to give you a basic
overview of the white mold facts so
we're concentrating on the disease white
mold and we'll just review some of the
strategies and tactics to control the
disease and that leads into the
rationale for our experiment looking at
the potential for rolled crimp cereal
rye to add to the control of this
disease in leguminous crops
we'll then talk about the field trials
specifically we've been doing this for
several years at geneva and the results
have been consistent
we'll talk about the rationale we'll
talk about how we designed the
experiment and our approach and some of
the results not just on disease but also
on the trade-offs of weed suppression
and on crop biomass and on yield pod
yield
and we'll talk about the implications of
our findings for disease management
in leguminous crops
so just as a refresher white mold is
caused by the fungus sclerotinia
scleroderm
you may know the symptoms of this
disease already this white cottony
fluffy mycelia that you'll find on pods
of dry beans and soya beans and snap
beans
but the fungus has a very broad host
range so it can infect over 400 plant
species
many of which are vegetables and field
crops found in our new york cropping
rotations which makes rotating out to a
non-host quite problematic to
to
provide an opportunity to potentially
reduce the inoculum density in the soil
now often crops have very low tolerance
for
white mold for example in snap bean
crops the
tolerance for crop rejection could be as
low as two percent
so over that two percent threshold if
pods are affected that could lead to
crop bypass
so it's important to get the management
very correct
so why do we worry about white mold
apart from crop bypassing well we have
direct crop loss in those crops
so the disease causes premature pod
abscission so they just fall off before
we get to harvest them
and reducing so we reduce the number of
harvestable pods
we can also reduce the number of beans
per pod because even though pods might
be harvested they would have less energy
going into those pods and therefore less
beans being formed within the pods
and sometimes the beans might be formed
but they have a poor quality that
because they didn't have enough energy
during formation they might be quite
shriveled and not suitable for sale
but we also have to consider
contamination of the fungal parts
such as the sclerosis these black
resting bodies of the fungus that you
see here
in the beans so that slows down the
process of sorting out beans from
sclerosia because of course no one wants
to find sclerosis in their can of dried
beans but there's a direct crop losses
but there's also indirect crop losses as
well
when we get the production of this
corrosion the resting body of the fungus
that survives in the soil
on the disease plant parts they fall
back into the soil surface
and then form the inoculum for the next
susceptible crops in the rotation
so it's setting up disease loss for
future crops as well so we have to think
about direct and indirect crop losses
so for white mold we for all diseases we
can represent diseases by this disease
triangle so we have the role of the
pathogen
the role of the environment
and the role of the plant and all those
three factors have to come together to
get disease in your crop
for white mold the pathogen we consider
is usually sufficient
in the soil at sufficient densities to
cause disease
so we can't alter management too much by
trying to reduce the pathogen level in
most cases
mostly because of that very broad host
range
the plants there's really no significant
resistance or immunity within many of
our crop species including legumes given
as crops
and the environment well that really
regulates whether we get a white mold
epidemic or not
so it requires very mild temperatures
very rainy type conditions which we are
increasingly getting
um within our new york area
so it's clearly that driven by that
dominant influence in spring and summer
conditions
the life cycle of the fungus starts as
these black sclerosia
so this is the structure the fungus uses
to survive between seasons in the soil
it's basically just a wrapped up piece
of mycelium and then they put this black
melonized hard coat around that to
dissuade any degradation by
microorganisms
and other environmental conditions
so that's the main driver of inoculum
for the disease
though sclerosia when the conditions are
right germinate into these what we call
apothecia but there's these little
mushroom type structures pale brown
mushrooms
on the surface of those pale brown
mushrooms we get the production of
ascospores which are basically colorless
balls that are wind dispersed
those ascospores can then only infect
the flowers
of our beans
and then they use those dead dying
flowers as a nutrient source to be able
to infect the green tissue directly so
whether that be a pod whether that be a
stem
it can cause chaos on a variety of
different plant parts as long as that
infected petal falls on that plant part
and then we get the typical symptoms of
white mold these bleached necrotic
lesions
and the signs of the pathogen which are
these white cottony fluffy mycelia which
then ball up
become black and then fall onto the soil
surface again
now i mentioned the role of the
environment
and this is really illustrated just for
example over the season between 2014 and
2017.
so
2014 it was a white mould year what so
to speak it was cool it was rainy all
year long and we got a lot of
significant loss
in our leguminous crops from white mold
in 2015 we didn't see much white mold
because it was cool but the rain
happened very early in the season so
that affected crop stands
which affected the microclimatic
conditions later on so crops didn't
reach their full potential and they
didn't get canopy closure
2016 the same happened but it was just
hot and dry all year round
and again in 2017 wet and cold
all season long and it was a white mold
year so we get these dramatic
fluctuations
in white mold epidemics between years
but what we do know for white mold is
that the inoculum comes predominantly
from within the field if the ascospores
don't fly in from down the valley or
generally the field next door
the inoculum or sclerosia that's in the
soil in that field
contribute to
the ascospores that are being produced
and those ascospores
get caught by the crop canopy and are
able to cause disease
if the ascospores do escape the crop
canopy and get into the wind currents
they're quickly broken down because
they're colorless and they're able to be
degraded by ultraviolet light quite
quickly
so
to concentrate on management we know
that we need to concentrate our efforts
on trying to reduce the sclerosis
density within the field itself
which gets back to our rock to our
potential for using
rolled crimp cereal rye to control white
mold in a field
so in terms of management for white mold
this is what we know so far
we've got these strategies so things
that we can do prior to planting to
reduce the sclerosis inoculum and reduce
the risk of disease
and we also have tactics things that we
can do within the season as well so
let's take a closer look at that before
we move into the rationale for our royal
trench cereal rye research
so for strategies we know that
increasing
our frequency of non-hosts if we've had
a problem with white mold in that field
in the past
is going to reduce the scrotial inoculum
because they won't have an opportunity
to infect those hosts
the only real non-hosts in our cropping
rotations unfortunately
are corn
and grain
now if we do rotate to those crops to
get the full benefit problem in terms of
reducing our sclerosis inoculum we also
need to think about weed control because
many of our broad leaf weeds are also
hosts to sclerotidy escaradiorum and can
also get diseased perform sclerosia and
sclerosis fall back onto the soil
surface
so we need to think about weed control
when rotating to these non-hosts so
we're not negating the effect of that
crop rotation
for disease control
and of course strategies we can also use
techniques agronomic techniques that may
have trade-offs
for example we could use wider row
spacings if it fits planters and
harvesters to get more airflow through
the canopy
we could use decreased plant populations
as well but again trade-off with yield
less disease less yield
we could also ensure that we get
effective weed management so we're not
clogging up our rows with weeds so we
can maximize the airflow through the
crop canopy and if they're available we
could use upright varieties again with
the main target of moving airflow
through the canopy
now we also have tactics within the
season that we can use for example
fungicides so there's a range of
different fungicides in different frat
groups or different fungicide resistant
action committee groups so that
represents different modes of action of
the fungicides that we could rotate
between if we wanted to consider
synthetic fungicides for conventional
production
but we also know from our research that
to get the most out of our fungicides we
have to be really accurate with our
timing of that first application with
early flowering because
covering and protecting our blossoms are
the critical point
to because our blossoms serve as that
inoculum source after they fall from the
flowers onto the input other plant paths
but we wanted to look at this the
potential control of white mold from a
different angle instead of controlling
the flowers which most of our techniques
do through fungicides
we wanted to see if sclerosia could be
inhibited from germinating to start with
so sclerosia are generally within the
first top inch of the soil profile so
those sclerosis that contribute to the
disease
in the field
lower sclerosia in the soil profile
won't germinate um sufficiently long
steaks what these these little stalks
containing the mushrooms to get to the
soil surface
so we wanted to try
and control or try and inhibit the
germination of these sclerosis so we
don't get ascospores to start with
so this is in principle done in other
systems where for example in the pacific
northwest
they use chemication so they put
fungicides through the irrigation water
to do just this prevent the germination
of sclerosis into these little mushroom
type structures to prevent ascospores
but we wanted to do it because through
potentially cover crops
as you know we don't have a lot of
irrigation infrastructure in new york
so what other ways could we
achieve the same aim and also get the
benefits of cover crops in terms of soil
health and climate resilience
so the objective of our research over
the last few years has been to quantify
the efficacy of rolled crimp cereal rye
mulch
on white moulds specifically the major
disease of our leguminous crops
weed populations biomass and yield
because again we're interested in those
trade-offs between the biotic stresses
affecting our legumes disease and weeds
and biomass and yield components
so when i'm talking about road crimped
cereal rye i'm sure you know about this
potential one pass system
so we're planting our cereal right in
early fall
we're letting it grow in fall and then
it will over winter
in spring it will bounce and grow very
rapidly
and then we're rolling and crimping it
to achieve a mulch layer on the soil
surface
so we're using a roller crimper bar as
you can see here it's basically just a
heavy cylinder
with these imprinted
rollers
imprinted in a chevron type pattern so
when you go over the cereal rye it can
kill it by crimping and damaging the
vascular tissue so it won't it will die
in place when it's pushed down and forms
that mulch layer
we can then do plant directly into that
mulch layer either in a one pass system
or it could also be in a two part system
so we thought it had application to
directly harvested dry beans
because
for directly harvested dry beans they
would be harvested in one pass
so they would not need wind growing
beforehand because the mulch layer could
of course interrupt in that
wind rowing process
and the system has already been
optimized in terms of its agronomic
attributes for soybean so we were
interested in a exploring this system
for white mold controlling both
susceptible crops but also looking at
could it be possible in dry bands
so the rationale for this for white mold
control
is
that we would like to know whether the
cereal rye mulch layer on the soil
surface
has the ability to reduce light to the
soil surface
because we know that light and the
ratios of light quality are important in
the germination of the sclerosia
into these little epithecia
so by reducing the light perhaps we
might get less germination
and even if they are formed perhaps at
lower frequency we might get dilution of
the ascospores because it's harder for
them to be released into the wing
currents through the rye mulch layer
and of course there's other benefits in
the the rolled print rolled crimp cereal
rye mulch layer as well such as
potentially weed suppression
soil health moisture
and reduced tillage as well so in
conventional systems every time we till
the soil we're essentially delivering a
new population of sclerosis to the soil
surface and as we saw before those
sclerosis that are right on that soil
surface within an inch or so have the
potential to germinate
by bringing more sclerosis up we're just
bringing new sclerosis for more disease
every season by tillage
so our trials were located at the
research north facilities at cornell
agritech in geneva
what we did was we planted strips of
cereal rye it was cultivar arrow stuck
at three bushels per acre on the 18th of
september
so we've done this over multiple years
but for ease of letting you know the
results i'm just going to concentrate on
the results of one
year our plots were 40 feet long by 204
feet wide in this season
and we rolled and crimped our cereal rye
on the 31st of may
as john paul said we didn't let it go to
seed we rolled and crimped it at 75
percent and thesis to soft die stage
and our main crops were planted as a bit
later than we would have liked on the
7th of june because it managed to rain
prolifically
just after we rolled and crypt it the
day after
we had two different crops
soya beans it was variety viking and
black bean which was varieties in it and
we planted our black beans at the
commercial conventional no-till phase of
eight seeds per foot and both crops were
planted with a 30 inch row spacings so
essentially we're comparing fallow areas
that were not planted to cereal rye
mulch cereal rye in fall
compared to our rolled crimped cereal
rye plots two treatments
this is the process
where we are you can see that the cereal
rye has produced a huge amount of
biomass
since it's planting in fall and into
spring
and this is you can see our tractor
going up and down our plots
rolling and crimping it into a mulch
layer on the soil surface
this is what our plots looked like in
may so we had
significant biomass and again we're
rotating our treatments up and down our
field
and this is what it looked like after
we'd rolled and gripped the entire
paddock
so the first thing we wanted to
have a look at was the effect of that
cereal rye mulch
on plant density so crop populations
and we found that dry beans there was no
significant effect
from the rye mulch the similar plant
density or plant populations in the
fellow and the cereal rye mulch plots
and surprisingly in the soya bean plots
we did get 45
less plant density in the rye plots
we also looked at crop biomass so once
we know how many plants have established
we wanted to look at their vega as well
and we did this mid-season 19th of july
and later in the season on the 31st of
august
so in dry beans in the 19th of july
mid-season we had significantly less 63
percent less biomass in the rifles
compared to our phthalo plots
and a similar effect on soybeans of
course we had that plant population
effect earlier in the season as well
but by the 31st of august there was no
significant effect on biomass from the
between the mulch and the fella areas
in dry beans but we still had a legacy
effect from that plant population and
potentially plant vigor effect
earlier on in the season in our soy
events 27 less in the rye plots
now in terms of yield we
hand harvested plants within different
subsamples across our trees
and we looked at pod weight and pod
number on the 12th of september
so for dry beans we did get a
significant increase
in pod weight in the rye plots
but pod number was not significantly
different between the treatments so
potentially we had significantly heavier
pods
because we had the same number
whereas in our soya beans we have our
pod weight was again reduced in our rye
clots by nearly 30 percent and our pod
number was not significantly different
between the rock mulch and the fallow
plots
now we also had some we've seen
repeatedly some interesting
crop maturity effects especially in
soybeans as well from the rye plots
so
in this section we have
the in the foreground of the picture
you can see our rye mulch plot and the
crop is still green and kicking on this
is well into september
whereas in our fellow area we're getting
senescence of our crop in soya beans so
potentially the
rolled mulch the
the rye mulch plots held onto moisture
for longer
which
made the crop kick on for longer
now we also saw a significant impact on
weed suppression from our
rye plots
so in terms of broad leaf weed biomass
at the end of the season on the 21st of
september
we had a significant weed population in
our crop but there was 65 percent less
in the rye plots than the fallow so we
were doing a good job with wheat
suppression and was the case in soybeans
as well probably
higher
in soya beans probably because it was a
a much more
lush canopy and which probably provided
more
weed suppression on its own as well
but let's
get to the crux of the issue which was
what was the effect on white mold
so we looked at the incidence of
white mold on plants and pods in the
mulch plots versus the fallow blocks
and in soya beans we had an incidence
in the fallow plots of 8.4 percent
we could not find white mold in the
varied plots
similar effects in the dry beans
significantly higher incidence of white
mold on plants in the phthalo plots
compared to the rye plots
now to look at the effect of the
cereal rye on spirocia
we dug into the ground at six sand
filled pots which we filled with
sclerosis six per plot
now these sclerosis were ready to
germinate once they had the correct
conditions
so that we pro condition them in the
laboratory to be able to make them ready
to germinate if they can
so let's look at the results of that so
what we were looking at for was whether
the sclerosis had germinated and if they
had germinated properly
so by that i mean that they've
germinated with their small stipes the
stool stalks plus the disc the apothecia
which contains those asca spores
so what we found was consistent between
the soya beans and the black beans
so for example the incidence of
germination that resulted in fully
formed apothecia with that disc and
ascospores
was significantly higher in our fallow
plots compared to our rye mulch plots
also this case in black bean but the
opposite was true for non-functional
production of starts so by
non-functional again i mean that the
sclerosia have germinated but they did
not form that disc and therefore no
asterospores
so we have
more in the cereal rye plots compared to
the fallow plots in both the soya beans
and the black veins
so this is what they look like
so just as a reminder we have
in the rye plots reductions
in the functional apatheti the incidence
of these and this is what a functional
apothecia looks like fully expand disk
but significant increases in the
sclerosis that are germinated to
non-functional stipes and this is what
they look like so they germinate they're
reaching for the sky but they just don't
have enough energy to be able to produce
their apothecia
so we believe this energy exhaustion of
sclerosia could be potentially useful in
a no-till situation
because
again those sclerosis that are only
within the top inch contribute to
disease and if we're not bringing up new
populations of sloshia by tillage
we're going to essentially purge that
upper layer of stereotype of sclerosis
which could contribute to disease in
future crops which may lead to a
reduction in soil-borne inoculum so
that's one aspect of our further
research into this issue
so in summary there's fewer newer
fungicides fewer
new tactics that can be used in
conventional systems being produced on
the horizon
but we believe
not relying on one
um one tactic or one strategy
is the future especially for these
recalcitrant type diseases that have
been with us for a long time
we need that systems types approach to
be able to make incremental gain in
disease control
rolled cramped cereal rye mulch could
offer that ability it provides weed
suppression we've demonstrated white
mold control
and potentially reductions in soil borne
inoculum
but the system needs to be abdominal
optimized for its agronomic attributes
with yield
so with that i'd like to acknowledge the
fantastic help of my own team the evade
team usually seen here
also the funding of the new york state
driving council and usda organic
transitions program
and our collaborators from the ryan
program and also brian brown from the
new york state ipm program
thank you
i will stop sharing yeah
wow super
innovative work there and applications
of the
roll rye system it's great to learn what
you're finding there i'm gonna
take a look at the time we have several
minutes for questions first due to end
around 105 so i do invite folks to use
the chat one question that's in there is
how do you think snappings would do in
this system
yeah actually i'm going to throw that
question back to you steve
would they be do you think they would be
held
upright enough for the direct harvest
um i guess it would depend upon the
cultivar
um probably depend on the cultivar it
could work it's fascinating yeah
i just hope they don't get more
susceptible to root rots because it's um
if there's more moisture underneath that
good rotation would be the key there
yeah
this is anecdotal and uh sean paul
speaking but um
we did in 2017 successfully grew snap
beans
uh through cereal rye and we thought the
difficulty would be
um that uh cereal vibe would be picked
up by the
bean harvester that was not the case at
all there was no trash coming into the
harvester
and also we had actually relatively good
germination there
um but again this is only one year
yeah that's really interesting thank you
thanks john paul
sarah you shared results from the one
year
were there was there much variation in
this trial from from year to year and
anything okay
there wasn't we actually had very
similar results over two years which
we've published
um but we're moving on to another
experiment to determine if it's the rye
residue itself
um or is it just rye for example
producing inhibitory effects
so with this time we have different
treatments of just fallow versus the
royal print cereal rye mulch versus
tilling in the rye as well before
planting
so is it an allelopathic effect from the
rye
and we're also moving into determining
to looking at this crop for white mole
controlling sunflowers as well it's also
a significant disease
that's super interesting i these this
concept of
of
of sclerosia in the soil and then
bringing them back up
to the surface i mean the analogy that i
was
went straight to my mind was in was in
weed management and bringing new weed
seeds to the surface and bringing
new sclerosis to the soil service
there's a lot of those analogies how
long can the sclerosis reside in the
soil um yeah we've actually got a
much of the data on that is from the
midwest
where you know it's very different
conditions so we've set up our own
experiment which has been going two
years now and so far they're kicking on
just fine
if they're
there's more degradation in sclerosia at
depth
rather than on the surface
you know presumably they're more
capable of being eaten so to speak
biodegraded by different microorganisms
in the soil so keeping them low
keeping them deep in the soil profile
also will enhance their degradation so
far in our experiments we've got another
year to go on that
[Music]
at least four to five years right
great thing you're sorry it was a long
version
very
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu